I did this Ray Romano movie Ray Romano
starde wrote it he directed it it's
going to be good he's actually a really
fantastic actor Ray Romano and he just
his directing style was great and if I
get to New York and then
I get a call and it's Ray Romano and
it's like it's so distinctly his voice
that I was like geeking out you know
what I mean because I've never met him
before and I was just like oh my God
Everybody Loves Raymond's on my phone
and he says hey man let's go out to eat
so we can go out to eat he says like hey
man you know you're I really I know you
auditioned but I knew it was you I
wanted you you were the you were the you
were the person I wanted for this and I
was like cool so then it's now it's time
to shoot I'm on stat I'm in my trailer
the clothes come in
and on the clothes they have like the
actor's name and it doesn't say Eric
Griffin it says Muhammad Amir
I go out and you know me I'm I'm that
dude so I go I'll go oh hey man I
thought I was uh the first choice
because it looked like he was like and
then he was like oh
higher but then he then he couldn't do
it you know because it was cheaper to
hire somebody local but it was just
funny that I just called him out on it
because it was just like people love to
do that making you feel like you're
special when you're not really special
but it's not it is what it is you know
what I mean they just they made they
wanted this person he's famous famous
you know and then they couldn't get him
so they go you know what let's get let's
get uh let's get Griffin so you know
that's a story of my that's a story of
my career